hi this is pressure Locker ancient
mythologies had interesting examples of
genetic hereditary x' in Roman mythology
for example Hercules was born of the god
Zeus and the mortal Alcmene II this made
Hercules a demigod he was one-half God
and one half human in another mythology
Gilgamesh is described as being 2/3 God
and one-third human this these are
interesting fractions and it raises a
mathematical question if each individual
is the offspring of exactly two parents
is it even mathematically possible to be
2/3 God and 1/3 human give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for the solution will
imagine a population where individuals
can be 100% God or 0% God which means
they're human what will happen if
individuals from this population
interbreed the next generation will have
people who can be 100% God if both of
the parents are God 50% God if you have
one God and one non God or one human and
0% God if two humans it will be
convenient to write these percentages as
fractions so we'll write the next
generation can have can be one God for a
hundred percent one-half God or zero God
now what will happen if individuals from
this population have children well we
can find the fractions of the next
generation
this can be one if you have two parents
that are God three-fourths one-half
one-fourth or zero and these fractions
because if parents have fractions a and
B of God then the child will be a plus B
over two fraction of a god now what you
can see from this pattern is that the
child will always have whatever the
parents fractions were the sum of that
divided by two and so that's the key
insight is that the child will always
have a fraction God that'll be a
denominator that will have two to the
power of something these are known as
the dyadic rationals so you can never
have a fraction that's equal to
one-third in fact the only way that you
could get 1/3 would be to have an
infinite series that starts with 1/4 and
has a common ratio of 1/4 so you could
end up being 1/3 of a God or 1/3 of a
human if you had an infinite family tree
but as it is you can never be 1/3 of a
god in a finite family tree so it's
actually impossible did you figure it
out thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math and game theory you can
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
which you can follow on Facebook Google+
and patreon you can catch me on social
media at pressure Walker and I like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description